this is likely the most recognizable
ringtone of all time the nostalgic
anthem of the early 2000s signifying the
transition into the new mobile world it
was a time when Nokia was the most
dominant cell phone manufacturer in the
world that controlled over 50 percent of
the entire Global Mobile Market selling
over 100 million phones every single
year this not only made them a mobile
giant but a corporate giant with a peak
market cap of nearly 300 billion dollars
but since then it has only been bad news
for Nokia as smartphones enter the
market Nokia's annual sales fell off a
cliff down to less than 20 million
phones per year their annual revenue
collapsed even harder as it crashed from
60 billion down to just 6 billion in
fact during the worst of it they were
losing 6 billion on an annual basis
meaning that their expenses were twice
their revenue Microsoft would try coming
to the rescue as they bought out Nokia's
business for 7.2 billion dollars but not
long after Microsoft would end up
writing off the entire acquisition price
plus more as a complete loss and they
would turn around and sell off the
remaining parts of Nokia for just 350
million dollars but despite all of this
Nokia is still somehow still around in
fact there's still worth just over 20
billion dollars they've even re-entered
the phone market after Microsoft left
and they're doing surprisingly well just
last year their smartphone sales tripled
as the Nokia c100 became the 15th
best-selling smartphone in the US as
such they've been posting some of their
best quarters in the last 15 years
pulling in nearly 5 billion dollars per
year of course this is still a far cry
from their once ubiquitous position in
the market but for a company that most
would assume went bankrupt years ago
Nokia is actually doing quite well in
fact you could even argue that Nokia is
super undervalued as their PE ratio
currently sits at just 5 five so join me
as we take a look at how Nokia has
managed to not just stick around but
recover in the era of smartphones
jumping straight into the beginning of
the downfall we have a Nokia's Apex here
2007. this was the Fateful year that the
iPhone was announced so it's not
surprising that it was also the peak of
Nokia but it wasn't all doom and gloom
in fact Nokia actually already had a
foot in the race before the iPhone in
2005 for example they released a Linux
based mobile operating system called
memo which they shipped with their Nokia
770 tablet they were also relatively
early to making touch screen phones the
first of which they launched in October
of 2008 but while Nokia had the right
overall idea they fell short from
several aspects starting with software
for the longest time Nokia was always
known for their Hardware they made some
of the most durable and reliable phones
on the market in fact people would often
describe their phones as being bricks
and that was a compliment but what Nokia
didn't realize is that people were
willing to sacrifice their ability for
functionality phones were rapidly
evolving from being calling device is
the being small computers something that
Nokia completely overlooked as such
instead of embracing Android and coming
out as the main competitor to iPhone
Nokia wasted her time making their own
crappy OS called Symbian Not only was
Symbian clunky and lacking basic
functionality but more importantly it
had virtually no support from developers
meaning that users were more or less
just limited to the in-house apps but it
wasn't just the software side of things
where Nokia was lacking pretty soon they
were lacking on the hardware side of
things as well it seems that Nokia
thought that Hardware just meant
durability as they would completely
neglect upgrading the internal
components and specs just think about
this Nokia was literally selling phones
that didn't even have 3G capability
while iPhones and Androids had already
moved on to 4G yeah it was really bad
speaking of Androids and iPhones Nokia
also dropped the ball when it came to
branding their smartphones Apple and
Samsung hit this out of the park with
the iPhone and the Galaxy branding but
when I came to Nokia there really was no
branding I mean just listen to these
names Nokia 5800 Express music Nokia 603
Nokia 701 Nokia 808 pure view like what
does 808 even mean personally I have no
idea and I think this is how most
consumers felt as well Nokia probably
felt that the Nokia name itself was
enough to appeal to customers which
brings us into our next Pitfall over
confidence Nokia largely overestimated
the value of their brand and it's not
surprising why they were basically
synonymous with cell phones but this was
actually a massive disadvantage the key
point to note is that Nokia was
synonymous with cell phones not
smartphones so if anything Nokia needed
to work extra hard to shift away from
this association with brick phones but
they ended up doing the exact opposite
as they let this Association Drive
customers to Samsung and the Apple so to
sum things up Nokia was extremely
overconfident while they dropped the
ball on software hardware and branding
but just as things were looking worse
than ever in the early 2010s they would
see a glimmer of hope from Microsoft
you see it wasn't just Nokia that had
missed out on the smartphone Revolution
someone else that I missed out and was
desperate to make their way back in was
Microsoft as such these two would decide
to join forces and take on the
smartphone industry together the first
step in this partnership was letting
Stephen elop a Microsoft executive take
the reins on Nokia in late 2010 elop
would join Nokia as their first
non-finish CEO and just a couple of
months later they would ink a deal with
Microsoft to become their primary
smartphone partner elop Justified this
gamble as a Hail Mary that Nokia had to
do to survive but really he had just
signed their own a death sentence the
problem with the Microsoft partnership
was that it solved absolutely none of
Nokia's fundamental issues take software
for example Windows mobile wasn't a
revolutionary OS that was designed from
the ground up for touchscreen handheld
devices like and Android or iOS was
Windows mobile was really just a janky
touchscreen version of Windows as such
developer support was abysmal meaning
that Nokia made almost no progress on
the software side of things in fact you
could even argue that they made negative
progress as they would start supporting
Bing and the Bing Maps things didn't
look all that much better on the
hardware side of things either Microsoft
was mainly just a software partner
meaning that Hardware was still largely
up to Nokia and as such Nokia would
continue to drop the ball when it came
to Hardware the Lumia 630 for example
only had 512 megabytes of ram no 4G no
flash no selfie Cam and a 480p
resolution screen and they had the
audacity to launch this in mid-2014 just
before the launch of the iPhone 6. it's
really no wonder why things didn't work
out but despite this their combined
overconfidence was higher than ever as a
Microsoft was even more overcome
confident than Nokia in fact they would
even go as far as staging a fake funeral
for Apple yeah that aged really well the
one thing that Nokia actually improved
upon was their branding the brand Lumia
was far better than just labeling their
phones the 603 or the 808 but given that
nothing else improved neither did
Nokia's position
under elop's leadership Nokia's stock
price crashed 62 percent their mobile
phone market sure halved their
smartphone market share fell from 33
down to three percent and the company
lost 4.9 billion euros
to make things even worse it seems that
elap was more concerned about saving
himself instead of saving Nokia instead
of pivoting to Android or even just
expanding to Android elop would use the
last leverage that Nokia had over
Microsoft to force them into an
acquisition Microsoft whose options were
to either give up on the phone market
right then and there or spend 7.2
billion dollars to have one last chance
would choose the latter honestly this
was a really smart play by elap for
himself as he would return to Microsoft
as an executive after dropping the ball
completely with Nokia but the same could
not be said about Nokia just because
Nokia had forced Microsoft to take the
plunge didn't mean that Microsoft
suddenly had a better strategy in fact
remember the Lumia 630 that they
launched right before the iPhone 6. well
that was after Microsoft took over yeah
I don't think you'd be surprised to hear
that after such failures Microsoft would
end up neglecting the phone business for
a few years before shutting it down
completely
foreign
[Music]
the Silver Lining about all of this was
that Microsoft didn't buy out the
entirety of Nokia if they had the entire
brand would probably be gone by today
but luckily for Nokia Microsoft only
bought out the phone portion of the
business but with that being said this
was their main business cenokia was
still left in a pretty bad situation all
they had left was their Network business
but looking back this may have actually
been a blessing in disguise you see it
selling off their phone business forced
them to figure out a way to survive
without their hero product and that's
exactly what they did they poured all of
their resources into revamping their
Network business and fixing all of their
previous mistakes for example remember
how they were previously neglecting 4G
well Nokia would become the first to
demonstrate a 5G ready Network in 2016.
they also stopped relying so heavily on
the Nokia brand because well Enterprise
customers care way more about the value
pricing and results over branding and as
for their overconfidence this was
naturally completely gone as they were
literally fighting for survival none of
these moves returned to Nokia to their
former Heights but it did Salvage the
business by 2017 Nokia would return to
the Fortune 500 as they solidified their
position as the world's third largest
telecommunications equipment
manufacturer only beat not by Huawei and
Ericsson and this recovery would be just
in time for Nokia to return to the phone
business you see after Microsoft gave up
on the phone business they would sell
off the remaining parts of Nokia for 350
million dollars this consisted of two
parts the first was the brand right
sonokia which were sold to a couple of
Nokia Executives who created a new
company called hmd Global the second was
the manufacturing and distribution set
of Nokia which were sold to Foxconn
shortly after this deal hmd Global and
Foxconn would enter into an agreement
that bring Nokia back to the phone
market and this time Nokia didn't make
the same mistake of partnering with
Microsoft instead they would partner
with a Google and bring the first Nokia
Android to Market in early 2017. to be
honest given how late they were to the
market it's unlikely that Nokia will
ever challenge the likes of Apple or
Samsung or return to their former glory
but that isn't to say that they can't
have a smaller profitable business
selling affordable smartphones which is
exactly what they've done in Q3 of 251
for example they were able to ship
almost 3 million smartphones so on an
annual basis they're selling about 10
million smartphones which again is only
a tenth of what they used to sell but
considering the disaster they went to
with Microsoft this itself is quite
impressive so circling back to the
question of the day of how is Nokia even
still around well after getting their
butt kicked by Apple Samsung and Google
and losing their business to Microsoft
Nokia returns a business world as a
humbled company instead of trying to
recapture what they once said they
decided to focus on salvaging what they
still had by focusing on networking
equipment and when Microsoft eventually
gave up on Nokia some of Nokia's
Executives decided to revitalize the
brand and become a small but successful
player in the modern smartphone World
instead of not being a player at all and
that's how Nokia managed to stick around
this story is completely different from
Microsoft's perspective if you'd like if
you're their side check out this video
but until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on next one